you
hey uncle Joey here with the [ __ ]
backdrop insane it's early in the
morning I'm already cooking [ __ ] but
listen that's how professionals do it
you know I'm saying if you're gonna sit
there and tell me about the new [ __ ]
but who gives a [ __ ] in my world you got
a spark this soldier
ah nice what the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with some novice you thought I
forgot about you [ __ ] it's sad
they baby
it's what the July week that people have
a car right now stuck smelling their own
[ __ ] farts and I'm being you I'm over
here living like a [ __ ] doctor you
understand me what do you know
one man's chicken is another man's
[ __ ] gumbo you know what I got today
that's I got nothing I'm just gonna be
Coco today with my family my daughter my
wife is haunted Yoga I'm gonna babysit
take it to the [ __ ] Park smoke some
more weed okay I'll call you
[ __ ] back up but right now
let's spark this because what's with the
chili challenge Oh
smartness and tremendous [ __ ] we take
about nine stars last night's solo
like that if you ain't blowing [ __ ]
clouds like that shoot yourself
[ __ ] sometime I feel good today
what did you did you went to [ __ ]
mobility class the tactical fitness
yeah I'm trying guys a 53 year old fat
[ __ ] but at least I'm not tapping I
ain't done yet
they ain't put me in a casket yet I
suggest they don't put you no [ __ ]
casket takes a lot more than [ __ ] it
up we gotta take this [ __ ] to
the hoop on a daily at Miami no smoothie
I had my [ __ ] CBDs now I'm smoking
the [ __ ] kale of life you know like a
doctor
because
from watching the jungle [ __ ] the
lion whatever Disney [ __ ] jr. hell up
was better than paint
watch it Disney on a Saturday morning
come on
and my wife gets back from yoga maybe do
a little breakfast maybe a little swim
it he'll loosen up the old [ __ ]
cadaver here
get the [ __ ] star mean get juice
ready in the nutsack
and that's it I'm keeping it simple I'm
keeping it [ __ ] simple I don't want
to drive no way I don't want to see no
body you know I'm gonna jump up and down
I don't listen I'm 53 I'm a [ __ ]
firecracker you think I'll it already
I'm the king of [ __ ] firecracker
I must have [ __ ] kept Chinatown and
lights for a [ __ ] year but now you
got a move on
nice very nice that's it I just want to
touch base with you guys let you know I
love him I'm doing the same [ __ ] as you
[ __ ] just getting my relaxing
chillaxing trying to plot my next move
Nietzsche
and that's it I have things to do people
to see I got nothing but R&R I'll be
checking in from time to time tomorrow
night the podcast eight o'clock we're
[ __ ] around so when you wake up
Monday morning BAM you got a podcast
waiting for you that's how much I love
you [ __ ] all right stay black
to be careful watch out for [ __ ]
firecrackers keep your eyes open I love
you guys I'll see you [ __ ]
later for it I thought I'm like I said
it
oh yay one time I beat up on it I love
you guys stay black